dimanche à saint germain en laye
l'équipe de france est en finale au
terme d'une compétition de trois jours
huit équipes nationales se sont
affrontés pour le tout premier titre
européen de l'histoire du beatbox car il
ne s'agit pas ici de sport né de musique
après avoir vaincu sous forme de battle
musicale la russie et l'espagne et
quatre membres de l'équipe de france se
préparent pour la grande finale puisque
la compet est à la fois en solo ou en
équipe on a chacun nos donne au vote
secret tant en solo et voilà et pour
l'équipe on a on a vraiment mis en place
toutes nos idées on a tous notre
spécialité en solo après en équipe bas
on essaye de rassembler un peu nos
forces voilà et puis voilà la technique
sont la france et la tique la france
c'est la technique et puis la diversité
des le flou et le flou dans le groove le
groove le flou tout le hip hop
e
sinon
cette discipline musicale qui consiste à
interpréter vocalement et les sons et
des rythmes a pris ses sources dans le
scat jazzman puis s'est développé avec
le hip hop je suis impressionné par le
niveau par les performances et aussi par
l'évolution qui a eu pas port en fait
tomber boxing parce qu'avant c'est la
reproduction des instruments qui avait
comme la batterie quand un éditeur comme
le scratch et puis au fur et à mesure
ils ont se sont appropriés tous les
styles comme l'électro comme le dob
comme tout ça donc c'est on a un panel
qui est vraiment important
sur le podium du premier championnat
européen de beatbox l'allemagne s'est
imposée la france est deuxième